Being part of this campaign is important for me...
...because I feel that, it's a silly thing to say, but our kids are the future.
You know, I'm very lucky to live in a city,...
...in a country that the kids can have a great meal or they can drink fresh water,...
...they can look after themselves and we're very fortunate that we have that.
One of the things that I've always been focused on...
...is making sure that other kids have that around the world.
That's what's important.
I want my kids to be able to understand that they are very fortunate that they have that.
But, other kids around the world don't.
And I will continue to fight for that...
...and I'll continue to do the work that I do for the 7 Fund for UNICEF...
...and for this campaign because it's important.
I'm David Beckham.
I'm proud to be supporting Goal 3 for good health and well-being.